le 1er avril 1957 on découvre enfin le
premier arbre qui produit du spaghetti
ouais le 1er avril le jour du poisson
d'avril
[Musique]
c'est donc en 1957 que la bbc produit un
reportage de trois minutes qui montre la
fameuse récolte des spaghettis en suisse
pas très loin de lugano une grande fête
où on parle justement de la manière
d'hydrater les arbres pour que les
spaghettis atteignent leur pleine
maturité durant les trois minutes du
reportage la voix hors champ et celle
d'un rite sheard drogba est extrêmement
respectée de la bbc qui très crédible et
donc qu'ils accordent de la crédibilité
aux reportages en le racontant entre
pikine les laits d'animaux
mais comment ça se fait que les gens ont
pu croire une telle histoire
venant de la bbc mais parce qu'à
l'époque en angleterre les spaghettis
tels qu'on les connaît aujourd'hui
ressemblait pas su revisiter offerts
dans des boîtes de conserve donc déjà
cuits dans la sauce tomate un peu mou
donc l'idée de savoir d'où ça venait ben
ça nous échapper mais d'où venait cette
idée là de proposer un reportage sur le
fait que les spaghettis pousserait dans
les arbres
libé vient de châu jagger qui caméraman
pour la bbc et qui s'était posé la
question d'où ça vient spaghettis
peut-être que ça pousse dans les arbres
tout le monde a commencé à rire de lui
puis lui s'est dit ben un jour j'aurai
ma revanche donc chances de jack va les
voir ses producteurs pour proposer
l'histoire à la bbc qui va accepter 8
millions de personnes vont regarder le
reportage
plusieurs vont écrire appelé à la bbc
pour savoir si c'est véridique
ce à quoi on leur répondait bien planté
un spaghetti dans la sauce tomate et
soyez optimiste c'est ce qu'on appelle
le flegme britannique où l'humour
britannique
choisissez
[Musique]